e a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul
mercato gaming di horror che mi avete
consigliato che praticamente appena
uscito ragazzi siete stati bravissimi
sua volta e quindi ragazzi ho deciso di
giocavo subito appunto per evitare che
me lo consiglia stret per altri quattro
secoli quindi direi di iniziare andiamo
sul game è giusta luminosità finché non
riesci se si va beh non importa non
farmi domande che sono impaziente
ragazzi ho visto qualche screenshot
visto gioco è fantastico il risveglio
svegliati bambina è sorbito fin troppo a
chi cazzo con questa cioè buongiorno che
ne dici latte biscotti prepara po vj
ragazzi è già una bambina che si è
svegliata in camera sua credo penso che
questo sia come al suo hub ei muri avrei
bisogno di questa macchina fotografica
prendi la fed bernanke cos'è una lunga
suonando davanti a te e poi non farmi
fine di un modo santissima quando non mi
fanno finire di leggere milano sui nervi
ragazzi si può già posso muovermi a
perfetto grande adesso tu amica mia
vi spieghi che cazzo ci fai a dormire in
un posto del genere cos'è la mamma ti ha
messo in punizione tale torrido armi
fuori in giardino
e che cazzo i giardino tra l'altro
presto space to jump sì l'avevo capito
la cantano l'ambientazione epica
non ho ben capito che cosa mi piaci fai
qui ma ci sei manciata lo sai è passato
molto tempo dall'ultima volta che ci
siamo visti e poi non ho fatto in tempo
come al solito non ho ben capito chi sta
parlando ma secondo me sta bambina se si
è fatta di qualcosa prima di andare a
dormire queste sicuro ora sta macchina
fotografica e fantastica ragazze nel
caso va male la vendo su ebay epica raga
e penso che la bici con entusiasmo
giusto e abbiamo bisogno non mons
la prossima volta che parla che non
riesco a fina di regia di fico un
cazzotto che non avete idea click del
mouse to use the camera flash paparazzi
due open detto ah cazzo fantastico cos'è
devo farle foto alle piattaforme raga
sorridete
mi sono accecato smettila di farmi le
foto lurida ragazzi evitate di giocare
sto gioco al buio perché potreste
diventare ciechi seriamente vabbè
andiamo avanti di qua devo farle proprio
alle 100 forme e tu cosa fanno l'africa
raga ho capito lo scopo di questo
videogame strasicura alla macchina
fotografica perché devo andare concerto
dei backstreet boys vabbè andiamo avanti
di qualche se non ho ben capito che cosa
stiamo facendo ma chi se ne fotte vai
cos'è vai vai così grande che ci sono
anche sicuri che non ho capito che
servono ma chi se ne frega andiamo
avanti
mi ricorda tipo lamentazioni questa ecco
la vecchia ville libreria aspetto prima
che torni indietro fuori dietro chi ti
ricordi il guardiano non me lo ricordo
devi essere al 100 con lui trova una
strada per buttarlo giù che cazzo era
quello ragazzi c'era un tizio abbastanza
enorme che pareva dormito una cosa del
genere e qualche giocattolo sta
bloccando la tua strada a li mortacci
nel cavallo ragazzi chiamati qualcuno e
fatelo spostare mai vi chiama un carro
attrezzi premier per fare una foto per
anche perfetto si fanno le foto posta
camera beh certo gear mai così ti tolgo
su facebook camera eccolo gara sei
venuto malissimo
adesso la condivido con tutti i tuoi
amici usa le frecce per girare la foto
devo usare le frecce per girare d'africa
cos'è la tua macchina fotografica è
molto più potente di quanto pensi mica
che fino ragazzi questo è stato epico
non ho idea di chi abbia inventato suo
gioco ma questa è stata una delle cose
più epiche che abbia mai fatto vi giuro
premier per fare una foto mai così di
nuovo ragazzi taglio su piogge scusate
un attimo prezzo space henrik di bitlis
sheikh default devo devo prendere questo
per per scuotere la foto vai vai vai
così fai così
questa è la nuova fotocamera dell'iphone
7 fantastico non c'è niente da dire
troppo epico veramente se faccio una
foto a me ma mi posso rendere più bello
no quello mi sa che non funzionava bene
un importo ragazzi andiamo avanti di qua
perché credo sentita questo è il tizio
in pigiama perfetto buongiorno sta
attento la morte ci ucciderà stufano ti
voglio fare una foto la mettere su
facebook quindi sorride poi di tag
contano ok non ti pago non ti tacco non
lo pago più i ragazzi mi sa che non lo
pago più ragazzi e fantastico lo voglio
anch'io il pigiama coin è un fantastico
se non ho più bisogno nella lucetta per
dormire e si danno ancora con la lucetta
non devo fare una foto perché i miei
capelli vanno a fuoco e perché è il
fuoco e bianco come una polare a chi
cazzo è posso fare la foto ok
all'orsacchiotto non si sa perché se si
è illuminato la trade combining sheikh
interni in action
allora devo prima se chiamare di solunto
così ok ok ca di giovani ragazzi ho
detto che dovevi fatti parla foto sono
poi son cazzi tua non ti lamentare
promesso faremo ce la faremo questa
volta perfetto ci ho pensato io tanto tu
stai solo lì a parlare e non mi fa
nemmeno finir di leggere ragazzi
ricordatevi che se non accettati di fare
le foto poi so cazzi vostri comunque ho
capito le per farlo c'è le foto le cose
che posso fotografare sono
muoviti bimba sta arrivando la parte
difficile a perfetto sta arrivando
questa non era una parte c'e questo
tutorial in poche parole va bene così
speriamo che è che è chiesto gioco sia
abbastanza lungo perché mi piace un
casino
questi muri sono stati la rovina di
qualcosa che non ho finito fottutamente
di leggere ma non importa se non saprai
mai la donna getting way è bastato non
leggo più baffa adesso lo leggo più una
mazza perché mi sono incazzato va bene
così sì figlio alla mia ma chi curia
nino già e cioè fatemi capire questa si
è svegliata in giardino siamo arrivati
non si sa questa mi sembra hogwarts
quando non la ripuliscono vabbè press
control a per camminare in punta di
piedi svegliando il famiglie che dorme
quanto siete brutti ragazzi ci sono dei
pezzi bellissimi sul muro atag anche voi
pupazzo e melo ragazzi a ma vabbè
andiamo dico a chi se ne bracci sono
piattaforme lì sopra fantastico prevedo
una passeggiata non cortissima quello
stupido uccello è andato via di nuovo
poi perché c'erano non ci tengo a
vederlo indovina un po zio ti taglio
anche a te su facebook è venuta mossa
quindi non l'hanno alla carica e
tranquillo sei tu l'uccello di cui
parlano tutti quanti non dovrebbe
riuscire a raggiungermi di qua se faccio
il giro
ok ok ok merda
qualche altra parte successo
un'esplosione esploso non si sa perché
bene sei morto
ragazzi siamo ci sono degli uccelli che
sono gli uccelli talco vado anche
sottoterra non si sa perché c'è un
bellissimo dottore è sempre bellissimo
corriamo via ragazzi che c'è un cielo
che fa tentando di uccidermi la mezz'ora
non so perché quanti ce ne sono visti
cosi maledizione è impossibile
suoniamo piano porno perfetto non lo
suoniamo più perché stanno uscendo
uccelli dal terreno ovunque
devo bene bene l'hai trovato e
flashdance painting non posso perché mi
segue un uccello maledizione qual quale
painting quello sì sì qualcosa ho fatto
speriamo che se ne tornino in gabbia
poiché si sta abbassando la gabbia che
non sarà porca [ __ ] mi fate fare
qualcosa maledetti uccellacci ragazzi
non si sa a perfetto ripartire ogni
volta faccio tre passi poi muoio e
ripartono a checkpoint perfetto animati
così che bello che sto stacchiotti già
avrei scommesso che sarebbe successa una
cosa del genere ma non i pivot le varie
classi ii perfetto far entrare la luce
vai così svegliati che mattina devi
andare a scuola mia mamma fa più o meno
così quando devo darmi la mattina a
genova del genere devo fare buttar giù
anche le travi sono ferme
è mattino svegliati che fa vj ha
preparato latte biscotti ragazzi siamo
che cos'è buongiorno sei tu il tizio di
prima che ho schiacciato mi dispiace
kutcher senti gestirsi a me non me li
fai abbiamo capito a premi e personale
all'olio di mozart posso posso
dilettarmi queste cose fantastiche mia
nonna da
ma che cazzo ma chi sa suonare meglio di
me mozart ma chi cazzo è sto mozart mai
così ragazzi devo devo suonare sta roba
a parte il fatto che mi sono preso
troppo bene
2 3 4 5 4 3 1 2 perfetto ce la possiamo
fare ragazzi due premunita va bene
facciamo così 2345 vedi che andava
meglio titanic 2 3 4 5 4 3 1 2 perfetto
magnificenti new media dopo tutto questo
qualcuno finalmente trovare pianista
giusto amici miei non trovate nessun che
sa suonare bianco natale
we are arbustivi don ce l'hai fatta ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi già abbatte a fare
qualcosa
la decisione la decisione un capitolo
fantastico cos'è
siamo sul fatto che ci corriamo credo
che qualcuno finalmente ce l'abbia fatta
ma cazzo amico mio mai mai hai mai
sentito suonare il bianco natale non è
il ricordo io abbia aspettato cui senti
io sei bellissima ma halloween era
inizio ottobre siamo a novembre zio a
fine ottobre scusate devo andare avanti
prima che tu possa urlare ho bisogno che
tu faccia qualcosa per me ragazzi quali
puzzle normalmente è diventato
mainstream
adesso questi sono i puzzle 3.0 a dover
rivedere solo intrappolando ci sono temi
potere per liberarmi ragazzi c'è un
tizio incatenatisi macchina fotografica
per liberarmi ragazzi mio dio mi sembra
di liberare un rottweiler però lo faccio
lo stesso perché poverino un nuovo ogni
modo si lamenta i carusi ho capito
allora facciamo così
novelli quanto sei bello adesso ti
lascio così come un [ __ ] la metto
come foto profilo per te come disposto
nel trafugare niente melo pupi
space va perciò così la eads io sono
buono oggetti libero perfetto stupido
fortissimo ragazzini prendeva per il
culo dopo però l'ho fatto veramente la
russa avete sperato che ti lascia che ti
ha mai lasciato scappare atti il sequel
sia perché cazzo è valentina no non cosa
non vi azzardate fanno finire così e non
vi azzardate ma non il diritto di
interrompere un gioco così stava per
battere il cinque a zio rottweiler ma
dai ragazzi io io non so chi non agosto
gioco ma è stato uno degli indie più
epici che io abbia mai giocato non lo so
fateci sapere se vi è piaciuto perché a
me mi è piaciuto un casino soprattutto
la parte in cui suonavo el'ala voglio
come suoneria quel pezzo lessona scarica
un ammette come suoneria perché sono
troppo bravo cazzo il latte biscotti che
lo prepari una zona ma devi sapere nei
commenti che ne pensate perché secondo
me è fantastico ma non lo so dite la
vostra congregazione al solito 6 vi sia
piaciuto lasciato sgomento mi piace
anche la poesia di facebook e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione per
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo il
prossimo video per ragazzi
[Musica]